Hello and welcome the fire of learning known as the British bulldog,
Sir Winston Leonard Spencer Churchill born in 1874 and died 1965 was a British
soldier and politician best recognized for his first term as prime minister
during the Second World War,
while a controversial figure to be sure he remains one of the most notable
figures of the 20th century as he oversaw the demise of the British empire,
but helped save Britain along with much of the world from the grip of fascism.
In this video,
we'll discuss 10 tips from Churchill that led to his achievements.
Number 10 attitude is a little thing that makes it big difference.
Church hill oversaw and participated in a large number of events in British
history.
He fought in three wars,
was a political figure in world war one and was prime minister who World War Two
and the early stage of the Cold War.
His ability to get not only himself,
but help his nation get through these things rested and keeping a positive and
strong attitude where many others would falter even in the face of devastation.
Number nine,
the best argument against democracy is a five minute conversation with the
average voter.
While this quote can be taken as an insult toward the common people,
it can also be seen as a warning.
Many leaders of Democracies reiterate that an intelligent and informed populace
is the key to a functioning democracy.
If the populists disregards politics and education in general,
then this may lead some to dean them unfit to rule and some figures may take
advantage of their obliviousness and assume more power over them until the
democracy itself is overturned.
Number Eight,
study history.
Study history and history lies all the secrets of statecraft very often in
history,
receipted same mistakes made over and over in my video finding our place in the
universe.
I discussed the fact that history is more than just a record of what happened in
the past within it our lessons and warnings for the future,
not only for statecraft but for any field,
and that is why is to study those who've come before you.
Number seven,
courage is what it takes to stand up and speak.
Courage is also what it takes to sit down and listen.
Very often in our lives,
we may feel that we know what is best,
they know what must be done,
we have all the answers,
et Cetera,
but sometimes we really did not.
The ability to consider that we may be wrong about something is an important
one,
and it may be hard to do for most everyone because no one wants to be wrong,
but we shouldn't feel as though being open to what others have to bring to the
table is damaging to our ego.
That is very dangerous.
And Churchill who warned of coming war with the Nazis as early as a twenties to
our British government that did not adequately listen.
It has a four right to make the statement.
Number six,
you have enemies good.
That means you must have stood up for something sometime in your life.
This quote is sometimes attributed to Mnm,
but it came in fact from Churchill.
There comes a time in your life when you have to develop principals and the sons
of integrity and inevitably there was a time when you may have to defend and
debate those principles.
Now,
of course with reference to the last quote,
the open to what others have to say,
but don't surrender yourself for the sake of peace either,
especially if what you're standing up for is not merely your principles but
yourself.
Churchill also said an appeaser is one who feeds a crocodile hoping it will eat
him.
Last number five.
Criticism may not be agreeable,
but it is necessary.
It fulfills the same function as pain in the human body.
It calls attention to an unhealthy state of things.
This quote is similar to number seven but distinct.
If we go through life unwilling to stand any criticism,
then we essentially view ourselves as perfect.
If we do not be ourselves as perfect and admit we have problems,
then criticism is a very valuable way to find ways to address our problems as
other people often have a perspective that we lack in ourselves.
Now,
of course there is a line where constructive criticism ends and you may have to
refer to quote number six when it does go too far,
but the rest of the time,
criticism is merely advice with a sting to it.
Number four,
success is not final.
Failure is not fatal.
It is the courage to continue that counts.
This quote makes sense with regard to Churchill's life.
He witnessed the end of world war one only to have to contend with the second
world war later in life and after there was success in ending the Second World
War.
It was not final because almost immediately the world was gripped by the fear of
a Third World War.
As the cold war began,
despite Churchill,
success is towards peace.
None of them were ever final,
but on the flip side,
what Churchill failed in life never stopped them from trying again.
No matter what he continued.
Number three,
history will be kind to me for I intend to write it.
One of the things that made Churchill who he was was his intention to
participate in life,
not the stick back and watch it happen.
Churchill through his actions did in fact write history and a very important
history of that.
He did not allow history to take him.
Number two,
we make a living by what we get,
but we make a life by what we give hill through.
This quote highlights his belief that what we give to the world is what makes us
who we are in his position.
Churchill,
his actions were not always that great.
As I said,
he is a controversial figure,
but there are may things which he supported and did,
which were for the benefit of mankind and those types of actions are what we
should focus on in our lives.
Number one,
if you're going through hell,
keep going.
This can be seen as immoral,
iconic wave saying quote number four,
but it strikes home a little bit more in our lives.
We have faced some very great hardships in Churchill's life.
He faced some very great hardships as well,
no matter what.
Even when it seemed as if he were going through hell.
He kept going and he told his nation to keep going through the words,
we shall defend our island,
whatever the cost may be,
we shall fight on the beaches.
We shall fight on the landing grounds.
We shall fight in the fields and in the streets.
We shall fight in the hills.
We shall never surrender,
and that is essential to Churchill's personality.
Churchill,
of course,
had a lot more to say,
but these were some of his best quotes.
Now at this time,
I'd like to thank our first patron support,
a Chris Yates for his donations of fire and learning,
and of course his donation amount gets him the opportunity to choose an upcoming
video.
As promised,
Chris,
your donation will be used to further the channel to support the creation of
videos like these.
A link to that patriotic we found in a description.
For more videos like this and video is on many other subjects be should have
take out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.